the comedy stories is me I mean
everywhere I go people know I'm
associated with the comedy story and
you're proudly associated with it it was
it launched comedy yes you know I don't
think anybody alive today of this
generation doesn't know or even without
knowing doesn't love somebody in comedy
that didn't have some attachment in some
way to The Comedy Store yeah whether
they were launched there whether they
were seen there whether they played
there whether they work out there and
that's where they put together their
Netflix special everybody everybody Joe
Rogan you know yeah is a product of the
comedy stuff I was just on his uh his
podcast last this last week and I played
his Club I know you played it as well
and uh the mothership yeah the
mothership in Austin and and like you
said you know what he's doing out there
is is remarkable you know he's in in a
lot of it you know has to do with my mom
yeah you know it has to do with uh you
know how she ran it and that's why I
love being there I love physically being
at his Club because I feel my mom my
mom's Focus there people ask me about
the club they're like what's up with the
club I'm like there's just a focus there
that you know what it was like it was
when my mom was running the club I said
that to him too you know I did his
podcast a couple of weeks ago and I said
and I dropped in on his club we did the
moon tower just for last Festival you
know I do the just for last Festival
which is one of the owners of and but I
dropped in on his club and I said not
since the uh mid 70s late 70s and early
80s have I felt that kind of excitement
around a comedy club a very that there's
four shows a night which are lined up
around the corner and they're so excited
and so electric to see you know anybody
just to the joy of the art form of
comedy and not since the comedy store
has there been a place where
it's just a must-see kind of place for
comedy yeah it's definitely I don't want
to see a tourist trap but it's a very
it's a tourist it's kind of like going
to see you know I don't know the Chinese
wax museum but in Austin you know it's a
place that Joe is built and uh they're
they're you know it's just everyone
wants to go like you said it's lined up
and um I really like being there with
him and I like being there with Tony and
I like that they named you know the bar
downstairs after my mom right and when
I'm in the bar I feel like my mom and
I'm there with Joe and we're like all we
do is talk about those days and we all
get emotional and we know we all miss my
mom because she wasn't just my mom she
was all your guys moms she really was
[Music]